I had connected with you back in May and
now since we put this on the calendar
you blew the [__] up cuz you went on Joe
Rogan that's right the goat Scoops me
once again he's never sco well all you
need here is is an archery range and a
couple of live life-size werewolves and
a picture of CLA Schwab over the toilet
you've got uh Austin scoop my buddy
you're on your way your trajectory look
at Joe he's saturating you know still
Rising he's got a CLA Schwab picture
above the toilet yeah so you're holding
your uh your your business and you're
doing your business and you're looking
into the cold BD of a I don't think I
could piss I don't think anything would
happen i' be a fre I like is it the old
age is it my prostate or what's going on
oh no it's clous it's these cold dead
eyes of the world economic Forum looking
at me yeah that's a whole if we go down
that rabbit hole we'll be there all day
but we got things to talk about but I
had connected with you because I had
meuk Kaku in for the podcast at I
recorded with him at the end of April
and so when that came came out I did a
little mini documentary that's still on
my channel now just covering kind of
like the 8 and 1/ half minute response
within the podcast that meu gave to your
friend Eric Weinstein's criticism that
he had had for meu a few months before
when he was on Joe Rogan and for people
that aren't familiar with that we'll
I'll let you explain the details but we
had gone back and forth and I felt like
first of all it it would be really cool
to see Eric and Meo in a room and I hope
if that happens it's you who does it
that would be really really cool but the
the core of that argument was over of
course String Theory which Eric has
presented his own Theory geometric unity
and string theory is obviously heavily
debated within the Science World because
it hasn't been proven but I I guess
where we stand almost 50 years since
string theory was was invented where
where where are you on that issue do you
think it's it's something where we need
to move past it now because it hasn't
been proven and can't be tested or do
you think it's it's a matter of it just
has too much too much of like a little
bit of an iron wall around it and we
should be looking at other opportunities
as well yeah yeah he asked a lot of good
good questions there so I'll start with
um I'll start with the original kind of
um statement about miio and Eric uh
first of all you have have to realize
it's kind of surprising that in this
very relatively Arcane abstruse abstract
form of mathematical physics that there
are battles every much as intense as the
East Coast West Coast Rap Battles of the
1990s that you probably don't remember
but I do know Biggie and Tupac and uh
there you go that's right uh not far
from here and then where I'm from on the
the West Coast um and so literally we
have East Coasters Ed Wht Mitch okaku
and uh then we have the West Coast gang
and out there with Eric and and others
taking an alternative approach so it's
surprising that there's so much heat and
passion that generated behind it and
partially I think I think the reason is
is that mathematics has always held a
special status in the culture
mathematics is part of culture it's not
divorced from it it's not some thing you
use as a tool to do something else um in
and of itself mathematics has a power to
Captivate the mind and I think
mathematicians and so forth are some of
the most respected
people in in the world for their
Brilliance for their intellect and so
it's very different subject from almost
any other subject in that things in math
are not not necessarily real in fact I
interviewed a a young
um she has a PHD in math but she's not a
professor named Eugenia Chang and she
has a book called is math real basically
does math exist so I always say can you
give me a triangle no but you can think
about a triangle can you give me a
complex number no but we can think about
a complex number can you even give me
Infinity no but you can think about
Infinity in ways that computers can't
even do it so there are these things
that are purely products of the human
mind and I think the Pinnacle of the
human mind is mathematics and and it is
the basis of all the physics and so
forth that I do now I'm an
experimentalist I build instrumentation
my goal is to see not if these people
are right but to prove them wrong my job
is to be the Exterminator of their
theories there's no such thing as a
proof in physics so you you mentioned
like we because we we don't have proof
or we can't be proven nothing in physics
can be Pro we can't prove there was a
big bank I can't prove there's not a
purple unicorn on Uranus I mean there's
no way to falsify every statement that
you could make about physics it doesn't
make it scientifically accurate but
mathematics you can so in other words
you can determine what is property of
mathematical perview in other words what
is kosher what is acceptable what is
part of the project of mathematics
because it can be proven or falsified we
may not be able to do it it took
famously 300 years between firmat you
know coming up with this Last Theorem
where he put it in the margins of of a
little paperback that he was reading at
the time before it was proven by Andrew
Wilds not far from from here in uh in in
in Princeton New Jersey and so you think
about things that can be proven it gives
physicist a little bit of Envy because
we can't prove anything in physics I was
going to say you you you don't really
have it it seems to me like even when
you look at some of the core tenants
like people will talk about gravity well
that'll probably never be disproven do
we know that though you know what I mean
because the think about how short human
history's even been to this point and
how much is out there that we have no
clue about like gravity for all intents
of purpose could be in an entirely
different
like I'm going to make up a term here
but like dimensional wavelength than we
understand it no yeah I'm not we we
don't talk about dimensional wavelengths
but we will talk about uh kind of an
analogy imag you put every theory that
every physicist has ever had onto a
pingpong ball and you put it into a big
55 gallon oil drum okay and you just
pulled them out 99 of out of every
hundred of those pingpong balls would
have a theory that was proven to be
wrong provisional Inc correct and I
think now it's no different maybe it's
even worse because it's never been
easier to phys theory is like software
you know it's it's easy to generate a
lot of software and say I'm going to go
back it's called technical debt you I'm
going to go back and fix up these lines
in the Cod I'm going to document
famously I don't know if you ever wrote
computer code I'm terrible at this did
i' love to write it super fun but you're
supposed to document what you're doing
so that somebody else can come and do
you know can do uh some some postmortem
analysis on why you have this bug that
led to you know 10 billion of you know
of alam coin to drop to zero or whatever
right so you should document it um I
never do it so that's technical debt I'm
going to go back and do it so it's easy
to produce it and forget to do the
documentation to do the technical debt
that you're supposed to do um but
experiments not easy to make an
experiment we're you know I'm part of
the leadership of a hundred million doll
project in Chile called the Simons
Observatory that's taken almost eight
years to come to fruition to get its
first Photon from the universe and it's
not even a photon from The Big Bang it's
a it's a photon from from uh you know
the planet Mars it's nothing that you
would write home about but that's how
long it's taken 380 people seven years
working on so you never do some like
it's not easy to produce experiments
it's very hard that's why every
experiment in my opinion should be
decisive it should have a clear-cut goal
what it's going to do because we never
know we we serve at the I mean if we
were living in Ukraine right now you
know we living in in um in Israel or
Gaza like we wouldn't be doing physic I
wouldn't be doing my colleagues wouldn't
be doing physics right now we'd be a
scared for our lives trying to figure
out how to survive um the other thing
we'd be doing is you know probably
working on a military you know project
somewhere a physicist would be working
on some military camp and this is true
throughout history physicists have
always worked hand inand or an
astronomers with the military uh and so
what's been really interesting to me is
to see that we only get to do this we
serve at the pleasure of peaceful
circumstances we do some of the most
esoteric as I said Arcane abstruse
things that you can do that actually
serve no purpose like what I'm doing
hundred million you could put that to
cancer research you could put that to
you know whatever you're saying and
maybe it would be doing more good maybe
it wouldn't or food just buying food I
guarantee or mosquito Nets it would
definitely do more good ultimately um
but uh but sometimes I think that's what
we should be doing because things that
have no quote unquote purpose are what
make human beings human and distinguish
and different I mean animals provide for
their their kids and there's even some
notion of altruism in the animal kingdom
as Steven Pinker and other people will
tell you right yeah so the question is
what makes us unique human it's doing
things that are
useless useless to benefit and it's not
going to make a faster although phones
did come cell phones did come out of the
research and radio astronomy that I'm
not that I did but the the Legacy that
I'm you know air to created the
technology right down the road here in
New Jersey in central New Jersey in
Homedale in a uh at Bell Labs the
technology that you're carrying in your
pocket right and that was concomitant
with the discovery of the origin of the
universe via the cosmic microwave
background radiation that I study so
getting back to your first question um
these guys are doing stuff that's very
important but it may not be very
significant in other words we Mayan
never be able to have evidence for it
now just because we don't have evidence
I don't have evidence for a supernova
what what blew up and created this
little piece of meteorite that I gave
you as gratitude for hosting me and I
give it all out to my uh visitors in my
website you go to Brian king.com I I
give those away four billion years old
four billion years old and I'll send you
the information about it uh when you
join my my email list you get the assay
the chemical composition you get the
origin and you get also a guy on how to
see meteor showers because I think
that's super cool and you can see them
here even in the middle of Manhattan y
you can see them you can see meteor
showers now and it's not going to be as
good as if you come to the dark desert
of California where I live yeah so it's
going to be a lot better when you come
and do my podcast I only do we'll do it
in person with you you made me come up
to New Jersey I'm going to make you come
to I will be there uh so anyway so we we
can look for things that we can't uh we
can't we can see the indirect evidence
for things that we can't witness that
Supernova produced that chunk of
meteorite that chunk is the byproduct of
a fusion reaction that terminated when a
star can no longer support its girth its
mass and it succumb the pressure that
was felt succumb to a nuclear fusion
event that then catastrophically
exploded that star out into the universe
how do we date something like that um
well you go to Tinder and no you that's
the only dating I used to no so uh so
these are dated by their composition
their their isotope ratios and also the
fact that uh they they can be determined
to have you know this the the the metall
the same metallic origin We compare with
a model for how these stars form and
then they end their life so there was a
star in our neighborhood of the Milky
Way galaxy that predated our Milky Way
galaxy and when it got to the end of its
life when it started to fuse heavier and
heavier elements together that no longer
gave off enough energy to bloat out the
star anymore to keep the pressure needed
to to counteract the gravitational force
of the of the outer layers of this
onion-like star um the last thing it
produces is called iron is iron and
heavy elements and that's why this thing
is so dense and you can verify it's so
dense it's also magnetic you can you
know stick it to a magnet very this is
magnetic yeah it's highly magnetic yeah
if you had one here if you have a
magnetic bobblehead maybe that I don't
yeah we got to get you one I got to test
that so um and the exact composition of
that meteorite is found in our Earth as
well and as as well as in the Rocky core
of our planet and and the other inner
rocky planets so we can date that they
came from the same Supernova so the
death of another star provided the
impetus the material the raw ingredients
that made our planet and also is then
found in the crust of our planet so
there's iron inside of the crust of the
earth that came from that same Supernova
that produced that iron chunk right here
and some of that iron made itself into
wheat and so forth that your mother ate
when she was pregnant with you and
eventually your body synthesized into to
make hemoglobin so the hemoglobin
molecule that fixes air that basically
allows you to live and breathe as a you
know as a breathing individual that uh
that iron came from the same meteor that
came from or came from the same event
that produced that now we didn't witness
any of that so why am I saying all this
because we also can't witness like
what's happening in 10 Theus 30th meters
and in a vibrating 10 dimensional super
string right that's not something we can
have access to but we can infer from the
Downstream effects what these models
would predict for things that we haven't
seen so if I see that thing there and I
say that same model predicts that there
should be an isotope ratio if if the
iron if what I said was not a lie okay
that the iron in your blood came from
the same Supernova explosion that
produced that meteorite then I've just
made a testable prediction you can test
the isotope ratio in your blood and it
won't be pure iron 56 or whatever it is
it'll have some isotope ratio and it'll
be the same as that and that came from
space that was witnessed the fall was
witnessed it's came from Argentina
you'll learn all about it when you click
on the the link in my uh in my
newsletter and that has a chemical assay
and it's very very similar to the
chemical composition in your body